good afternoon everyone welcome back
we're gonna start right away because
there is quite a lot of ground to cover
in today's session I'm going to very
quickly recapitulate what tea is about
what the whole space of valuations is
about I'm going to focus on some of the
more dicey questions regarding
valuations as to why should be value and
is it ethical and in what context can it
be done and with what sort of
methodologies and with what level of
appropriateness can those methodologies
be applied and so on but before that I
also want to give you an idea as to what
the valuations and foundations of t-bar
about the ecological and economic
foundations which is effectively the
first seven lectures and I'll talk to
you a little bit about each of the these
areas that will be covered for you by
the visiting speakers as you know all
together in this course we have more
than 12 maybe 13 even visiting speakers
and out of those four are actually
dedicated to this opening session and so
these first seven lectures are actually
vital for you because without these I
unless your your background happens to
be from there you won't really
understand the theory I won't say much
about teeb I think you've seen the
background to this project before and I
will say this that the reasoning fatigue
really boiled down to something like
four big reasons well I think the first
one of course is that the economic
invisibility of nature is a problem
there's that lovely quotation all the
way back from Benjamin Franklin which
blames our inability to value things as
the source of most of our problems and
if we look around us certainly that is
the case in ecosystems and in
biodiversity the rates of losses are
largely in my opinion attributable in
some form or the other to the human
inability to recognize their value or to
demonstrate their value to each other or
to capture that value in our policies
and our mechanisms and our businesses
now the second problem the second reason
why I think tea biz is important and why
it's necessary is because he brings
together a vast
knowledge from different areas it's a
combination of ecology and economics and
policy analysis it's a combination of
business thinking all of that has to be
brought together and these very
interdisciplinary approaches tend to
somehow get missed because to this day
Yale is probably an exception but to
this day most learning Institute's are
organized in silos and what you learn in
one silo you tend not to pick up from
others so we do have an issue here in
terms of bringing multidisciplinary
knowledge to the table and doing it in a
way which responds to local and country
level and regional policymakers and
businesses and thirdly I think the
business and the policymaker and the
administrator themselves comprise it in
fact different end-users their
decision-makers all of them will affect
the way biodiversity survives or the way
that ecosystems manage but at the end of
the day their perspectives are different
their drivers are different and for you
to engage them in any meaningful way on
the ground you need to speak differently
think differently know differently
sometimes and I think that's what team
does because it's written separately as
four separate books for the policymaker
for the administrator for the
businessperson and for if you like the
citizen and lastly I think there is an
issue here in terms of where we have
successes on the ground I don't think we
are doing enough to broadcast them or
teach about them I certainly don't think
that they are being tried enough in
terms of their replicability tested
enough in terms of replicability and I
certainly don't find many of them being
scaled enough in terms of being relevant
at a national scale or relevant at an at
a regional scale or even a biome scale
for that matter so I think these are the
reasons that we need to to focus on team
finally there's a whole issue itself
which is will be dealt with quite
success substantially later in the
course which is the whole connection
between poverty and biodiversity and how
many of you have read environmental is
about the poor it's quite a landmark
book yes one just one well it's it's
probably something that you get onto our
list but it's a book that outlines and
describes why why incomes and
livelihoods of the poor are so
significantly impacted by nature the
reality is as we saw from some of the
analysis that is there in the green
booklet
that ecosystem services is a proportion
of the livelihoods of rural farming
communities in India in Indonesia and we
are talking about hundreds of millions
of people here or for that matter forest
gathering communities and not just five
ten or percent of their of their
household incomes we're talking about 50
to 90 percent of their household incomes
that's why it is so important the poor
get a lot from nature any viable model
of development needs to recognize that
reality the base upon which more actions
should be built and finally if you think
about the key reasons for ending this
economic invisibility I'd see them as
five different reasons firstly that the
sheer size and scale of the losses to
human welfare as a result of the loss of
ecosystems and biodiversity are too
significant to ignore anymore are we
talking about trillions of dollars of
natural capital per year being wiped out
as a result of business as usual as a
result of the pace of losses these
business-as-usual losses do exacerbate
poverty and the earlier point I made
regarding the significance of ecosystem
services as a component of of rural
livelihoods it's an example of that
thirdly there are economic solutions we
do have examples of success of course
there are a few failures as well but
there are many examples of success which
deserve a bit of light a bit of
communication a bit of replication at
him and certainly a lot of scaling
fourthly there is employment potential I
don't think any government has to think
too hard to be able to build a set of
roads or bridges or add to an
infrastructural network as a quiet way
of adding to employment or pulling
themselves out of recession we certainly
seen two and a half trillion dollars
worth of expenditures of various kinds
investment on others arrayed by the g20
just just when the last recession hit
but when it comes to investing in
ecological infrastructure as against
physical infrastructure suddenly
government's balk at the idea and the
work of the idea because essentially
these are once again invisible assets
and it's very difficult for them to get
the mandate as it were from the
to approve a scheme which employed
millions for instance to rebuild forests
Ori build Lakes or rebuild soil
fertility for the sake of argument it
the attitude changes when you're looking
at natural capital versus physical
capital it is psychological as much as
it is anything else
and finally we do have on the same vein
to start reflecting natural capital in
our economic compass we have to reflect
it in our system of national accounts we
have to reflect it in the way that
business accounts are measured and if we
don't start measuring them and
reflecting these in these accounts and
we can never going to manage national
capital in any sensible way now as I
said there is a kind of feedback from
policymaking to the underlying because
one of the the issues that come up with
the policy-making suite is the role and
significance of valuation and of
economic analysis and it clearly
emphasizes and re-emphasize it that
these valuations and these economic
analyses are basically inputs there are
inputs to decision making they are not
de state the decisions themselves and
secondly they bring information to the
table in order to prepare those inputs
so there are these two layers which are
always there the information and the
decision-making toolkit that are
provided and finally it is the
policymaker that has to make those
decisions let me begin an introduction
to evaluation by quoting you a question
that was put to me at least 20 times in
the last last three years and ironically
this question was also insisted upon to
be the title of a speech that I was to
give in Australia in the Sydney Opera
House well I couldn't early argue
because the NGO in question are very
good friends and they said no this is
what it has to be and they were paying
my trip so in addition to that I said
fine I mean if you insist what's the
world worth I will talk about that so I
said all right was the world worth means
what's the living fabric of this planet
worth so let's imagine a planet which
doesn't have the living fabric and no
prizes for guessing which one this is
it's Mars so no biosphere and no forms
of life you know human beings
no interactions no economy value of
economy zero when I said all right well
now let's imagine a planet in which
there is a biosphere one which is
slightly more familiar and yes there's
life-forms and human beings and
exchanges between those human beings in
society and an economy ie one economy so
you've basically the marginal value of
having a biosphere is one economy minus
zero economy divided by the original to
zero economy that's one divided by zero
that's infinity thanks very much
that's the answer and I walked off the
stage I actually walked off the stage
and of course this was Australia so I
love doing that because I love putting
the legs of Australians but they clap
they got the joke so anyway and then I
came back and then talked about you know
what this is really about it's not about
the value of the universe and I think
someone said that I think is it's
medicine who said that in it's not a
question of Darth Vader pointing a gun
at you and saying I'm going to destroy
this planet if you don't pay me X and
the X is whatever 38 trillion dollars
it's much more about recognizing things
on the ground but having said that I
must say that I have to address this
issue of these big global numbers just
simply because of the number of times
they keep coming up in policy decisions
conversation drift was well there was
this study in nature and well there was
this that and then you know what was it
that you know you people had a study and
you said the losses were how many
trillion was it yes and then suddenly
there's a level of wakefulness as a
result of the big number it's almost
like an incantation you know like like
you sort of puja in in India where
there's a god called Ganesha and we
begin everything with ohm Shri Ganesha
ulema so in that sense almost every
conversation begins with this
incantation of the big it's almost as if
we are sort of beholden to what is big
and that's probably psychological as
well it's just the nature of our
societies to be impressed by whatever is
big so a big number of services or a big
loss I think sort of gets people's
juices going and then you have a
conversation and you move on from there
but the two studies that I refer to
which keep getting referred to is
Costanza study in nature that's in 1997
this is being criticized and I think the
reasons for that as well because they
were certain extrapolations applied
which one would question and also the
whole issue of like why would you need
to know and
could you imagine an answer which is the
total value of ecosystem services well I
think what Bob Costanza was trying to do
was to wake people up because this issue
was so invisible that he needed a kind
of shock treatment for people to wake
them up and I think he achieved that
quite successfully but as an academic
exercise that has been criticized and
what that concluded was that well the
total value of if that were possible of
all ecosystem services not were actually
in a range that is eighteen to sixty one
trillion dollars at a time when the
global economy was only GDP wise was
only twenty five trillion dollars so it
was clearly big and the average was some
thirty eight trillion and out of that
the ocean biomes had 2/3 of 24 trillion
of that value and in per annum and 14
trillion for the land-based biomes now
once again the ocean biomes were a
question of multiplying large areas by
small numbers you get large numbers this
logic has actually been used by a more
detailed sort of and thoughtful study
which still uses the Costanza numbers
but does so in the context of protected
areas so they are not arguing about
global --'tis they are saying that all
of the world's protected areas the value
generated by a model where we are going
from where we are today as in nothing of
the oceans conserved and about 10% of
the Earth's land can be conserved to
something more like 30% of oceans
conserved and 15% of lands conserved
that change in in policy if it were
policies global policies if it could be
achieved would drive a change in value
of X and that X is going to be the
securing of ecosystem services of the
order of four and a half to five
trillion dollars and securing means that
well you will not lose them in other
words you would lose about half these
ecosystem services some fifty four
percent and you won't and therefore
that's the value of having that
additional conservation and to give you
a sense of was the spending big or small
the forty five billion that Bamford
calculated well at that time in 2002 the
total protected areas were being were
absorbing something like six and a half
billion dollars of government spending
globally so actually forty five billion
was a steep ask to increase it Sevenfold
the key result of that global
calculation the big number there if you
like was not the five and a half
trillion because we've seen that before
wasn't even the forty five billion but
it was the ratio the fact that by
investing only this much a little sliver
you could secure ecosystem services from
the protected area networks which were
about a hundred times bigger and of
course a benefit cost ratio of a hundred
to one
it's got to be impressive now of course
that it again hinges upon guess what the
Costanza study because in his
cost-benefit analysis at the end of that
report he actually uses the total values
but after having multiplied them with
various factors to account for the sort
of the reality of of of the ground and I
think if he were to have redone his
calculations based on not taking the
ocean biome assumptions the sort of
scaling up which is which is challenged
then the answer would have been more
like forty to one but the fact is even
at a forty to one level which is like
deflating the ocean biomes values to
almost nothing you still have quite an
aggressive multiple and that's where the
value lies is in that it is possible to
put in investment in natural capital
ecological infrastructure and generate
public goods and services which were not
really generate but rather secure public
goods and services values which are of
the order of like forty times as much as
that so again big numbers but my
question to all of these big numbers is
something else never mind whether the
fact that they are addressing a
hypothesis of Darth Vader hypothesis or
whatever well never mind you know even
if they are right or wrong but who is
gonna use them there is no such thing as
a president of Earth or a prime minister
of Earth who calls this cabinet tomorrow
morning says guys you know we have this
big problem the scientists of pointed
out and we must do it doesn't happen
that way right just see how long we've
been negotiating the U n F triple C's
climate agreement and how far have we
got global solutions are not easy and
there's only limited value and having
data information provided as toolkit in
the way that policymaking t p-- talks
about at a global level but what does
matter is if you provided one level
below at the country level or even more
it matters if you provided two levels
below at the region level and even more
if you provided at the community
that's when things start happening
because then you know whose problem it
is you know who has to solve it is the
people on the ground and that's when you
begin to see traction policy traction
administrative traction business
traction so this brings me to teeps
perspective on valuation and our
perspective is not this so teeb teeb is
not a cost-benefit based sort of
solution for stewardship of the entire
earth that's clearly what it's not we
are not here into pricing bees and
butterflies and by the way someone tried
that once on me so someone who might
have to be careful what I say but
someone senior in a large and
international NGO actually thought
that's what tip was going to be about so
way back in 2008
Magan Zia was dragged into some public
park in Bonn with two cameramen
and questions being asked me so what is
the value of that butterfly mr. suketaro
and I'm saying well I've no idea and
neither will I work it out why why
wouldn't you do that or for that matter
that rosebush well you know I'm not
interested why are you not interested
because by this time the question I was
getting alarmed because you know I
wasn't giving the right answers so I
said well explain hang on this park has
two entrances as you can see we both
walked in free if you really want to
find out the ecosystem services
delivered from this park do some kind of
a willingness to pay calculation and
then and put some tests in place you
know we might find out what the
ecosystem services of this park are
worth as part of city biodiversity and
the guy was just totally disappointed
because I hadn't come out with the price
of a be over ever it is of the price of
a butterfly or a rosebush but thank God
the good news is that he never made that
movie although he did film me for like
one are asking these questions
and that is clearly not what TV is
around and neither was it ever intended
to be but Teebs perspective on valuation
is is Monia much more nuanced it is
about the various layers at which
societies recognize value recognize
value as in we know something's valuable
if it's if it's one of the several
thousand sacred groves in in hamachi
Pradesh in India then societies know
that they're valuable because they will
die rather than let that be lost
they know it's a particular destination
or a particular location then they are
connected to it's very
and it's worth infinity to them anyway
it's worth their lives
you can also demonstrate value and then
you can also capture value but these are
sub layers within that but recognizing
of value and what we highlight in
through T is that there are typically
five types of strategies and I call them
strategies because that's the broadest
loosest term that I can use here there
are regional plans which respond to the
value of nature of ecosystem services
there are legislations which are enacted
after all most of the protected area
system here in the US or for that matter
in the UK and elsewhere the early parks
national parks were founded based on
some idea of patrimony some idea that
this is heritage value it belongs to the
community and therefore it must be given
its pride of place they didn't come
outside of that and those same
strategies can of course be translated
into norms and regulations at one level
and policies and at a smaller level in
terms of demonstrating value there are
economic mechanisms certifications
protected area evaluations payments for
ecosystem services and these capturing
Zoar value these capturing the value are
still not markets strictly speaking
because there are not many buyers many
sellers they're usually bilaterally
negotiated it's not as if there are many
instances and price discovery happening
on an ongoing basis a typical
marketplace would have that would have
depth order of liquidity would have
transparency and would not would have a
degree of commoditization but here we
are not talking about that we're talking
about one community north of Beijing
negotiating with another Prefecture
South in the city of Beijing for the
value to be ascribed for using less
fertilizers and pesticides in order to
improve the quality of water supply into
the city
that's hardly a market place although
they may apply market thinking certainly
an economic mechanism but it's not a
market place there are lots of examples
in Tevan this is where the database
comes into use this is in sich one in
Buxton County in China where they
actually changed their land-use planning
so this is at the recognizing value
level based on ecosystem services high
value low value this is the Philippines
where legislation was introduced as in
the
wake of the of the bleaching event in 98
and it delivered economic value it was
calculated after the event this is the
classic example of demonstrating value
of a swamp which was going to be dam but
wasn't eventually because it was found
that its potential value as a cleaning
mechanism for human sewage was higher
than its alternative use and this is the
example that I've used earlier for a
protected species being reintroduced
making use of organic farming as a way
of reintroducing its its habitat and
economically it works both at the farmer
level because they get premiums on it
so-called white stock rice which has
been reintroduced it works at the
prefecture level because they get an
additional income almost ten million
dollars a year thanks to tourism and
that amounts to something like 1.4
percent of their total revenues and
there are literally a hundred and ten
odd cases here in in the database so I
do encourage you by the way how many
people have explored this already yeah
yeah that was a marketplace discovering
yeah and there were actually two levels
there was an organic level and there was
a friendly eco friendly so the the
strict organic goes at 50% was odd and
the eco friendly goes at about twenty or
percent premium yeah and this is still
very much small-scale though it's not
it's not I wouldn't call this scale of
life so I didn't call it replicable yeah
so how many of you have gone into this
website this is gonna be pretty useful
for you when it comes to local local
policy okay not money look I encourage
you to do this because there's stuff
here which you will find illustrative of
pretty much everything that we talked
about so finally a checklist for
valuations and I'll illustrate with a
tee valuation firstly it's about not
totalities but the margin what are the
marginal costs what are the marginal
benefits it's about being context
specific you need to know what was the
purpose of valuation was a green
accounting was it was it came in for
ecosystem services and was it one of
these mega studies to make a point to
legislators are not listening what was
the purpose it has to be location
specific to be meaningful even if it's a
mega study it has to be location
specific because there's only this much
that you can do in terms of
extrapolations and it has to be scenario
based as in you're comparing marginal
values between what and what
between scenario one and scenario two so
what is scenario one which is usually
business as usual scenario two is some
change in something usually it's change
in policy it could be a change in
climate it could be a change in other
land use for instance but usually it's a
policy driven change so the scenarios
are usually policy scenarios and finally
modeling has to be done with extreme
care because the kind of glorious
assumptions that sometimes can be made
are really very distressing and modeling
also means not just on the benefit side
of the cost side because one of the
crazy things that we've found is that
even though for instance there were
20,000 restoration projects which were
brought to our attention when we were
trying to make the economic case for
restoration as a form of adaptation out
of those only about 90 had costs
calculated properly and out of those
only about 18 the cost calculations were
good enough for us to use so we had to
speculate about the benefits but we knew
the actual cost
those restoration projects to be able to
work out cost-benefit analyses more
recent analysis has collected as many as
91 case study with over 20 odd thousand
restoration projects and and like 0.12
0.4 percent of the total number actually
has decent cost calculations it suggests
that there is negligence in a lack of
appreciation of the importance of
keeping this information by those who
are actually doing these projects I'll
give you an example from a study which
is not yet released please don't talk to
the press about it as yet which will
come out I think sometime a month from
now which is basically a global analysis
but probably the last one that needs to
be done which I think has been done on
the correct way which is that it doesn't
make vainglorious assumptions about
benefits transfer it doesn't assume that
it can decide what the scenario is in
fact they were eight scenarios for which
this study was done and all of these
eight scenarios are on the basis of a
survey that was done to actual
policymakers in 55 countries they were
surveyed and on the basis of their
inputs these eight scenarios were chosen
amongst the whole several dozen
scenarios and these scenarios are one is
to do with a great productivity another
one to do with reducing post-harvest
losses another one about protected areas
etc but these are actual scenarios and
the benefits transfer that was done
because of course several thousand
studies were pulled together in order to
get ecosystem service values from these
small biome patches that were analyzed
but the number of biome patches was not
one or two it was two and a half million
of them two point four six million biome
patches on which the benefits transfer
function was built so this is the kind
of detail that you need to get down to
now thankfully we had the GIS model
which backed this benefits transfer it
was a GIS model that gave this sari the
strength to do that benefits transfer
with the levels of detail that makes it
a meaningful study otherwise it would
just add to the ranks of you know the
big global number kind of studies now
it's also set up I think in the right
way which is as a benefit cost analysis
because it calculates the cost and
amongst the costs are the opportunity
cost of alternative land use and in
these scenarios it does this
cost-benefit analysis and you can see
from here
from column on the right-hand side that
there are two studies which are
increasing agricultural productivity and
reducing deforestation and the latter is
connected with implementing red plus
which are the ones which really give you
solid positive gospel benefits vs. costs
and there are others such as just
bioenergy based climate mitigation is
anyone surprised by that number the fact
that bioenergy based mitigation delivers
only one tenth of the benefits versus
the costs anyone can suggest me an
answer as to why this might be the case
just imagine growing biofuels yeah
please in growing them yeah that is that
is much better quite true and the
land-use change in addition to that
energy energy equation there's the
patentees equation because very often if
you do it in skies you end up destroying
rainforests and therefore releasing more
carbon in the end of the day which has
an economic cost still however you want
to use for that so it's combination of
those factors yeah so I think this kind
of scenario analysis still makes sense
if it is sensible to look at things from
a global perspective but I want to get
on today to the second half of our
conversation here which is basically
about the key themes of team and all of
those themes take you down take you down
to the local level they take you down to
communities and where things matter
so there are five themes that I'd like
to highlight here which have been
brought up in your reading in Chapter
four a lot of this is discussed in
Chapter four some of this is my own
perspective on it
so please do read chapter four don't
assume that if you heard me you don't
need to read the chapter that is not the
case firstly I think I I and Antibes
feel that the whole issue of valuation
sometimes gets treated too lightly as in
something you can just you know roll up
your sleeves and start doing and the
reality is that's not true you really
need to think about why are you valuing
and what are the impacts the
implications long-term to society and to
the country concerned our author the
community concern of going along this
valuation route we've not valued
relationship for a long time if we
suddenly flip to doing it the question
is what does that mean to the society
technique it's important to recognize
that it's a human institution and who
exercises this discipline who conducts
the valuation actually makes a
difference thirdly the purpose has to be
totally clear and transparent can't just
produce numbers and then figure out
afterwards what to do with them
fourthly there are uncertainties we
don't understand enough about ecosystem
services we don't understand ecosystem
functioning in sufficient detail we
don't know enough about the dynamics we
can't predict climate change and it's
impacts on ecosystem
etc etc and there are also risks
involved in monetizing or going to a
path which may lead to monetization and
finally discounting which is at the
heart of pricing any capital asset
you're looking at benefits you are
speculating what those benefits are
going to be in future you're projecting
into the future
that's one degree of uncertainty and
then you're also using a discount rate
to say what are those benefits in the
future worth to us as a society today so
you're using us what we called a social
discount rate and that involves an
ethical choice and then the question is
why did you make that ethical choice is
it the right one is it the wrong one etc
so the questions that come to mind that
should come to mind is we hear everyone
hears about interest rates you don't
that often hear about this country it's
except in corridors of of learning
what's the difference is the discount
rate and interest rate is an interest
rate a discount rate the answer is it
can be in certain circumstances if
you're discounting cash flows there is
something called an interest rate in
each currency which can be used for
discounting a cash flow but that's only
if it's a certain cash flow what if it's
an uncertain cash flow R well then you
have to add a credit premium then
suddenly the interest rate that you
apply is actually a credit weighted
interest rate and that becomes somewhat
different and so on secondly the
question to come to your mind does it
matter what we are discounting I mean
discounting cash flows not was
discounting the receipt in a bond or
discounting the return of cash on a
deposit that's one thing what if I'm
discounting goods as in what's the
marginal value to me of my second car or
my third television set then there's an
issue to be asked here and how does this
value change over time
what would I swap today for tomorrow for
instance I have two BlackBerry's right I
have a certain value on them yeah it's
interesting me you'll find that I place
more value on this blackberry because it
slightly older and more used to using it
and this one which frustration confuses
me every now and again so firstly that's
not a perspective that is a personal
perspective if I went to the shopkeeper
and asked him how do we value he'd value
it this way so automatically that
valuation is different depending on who
you are how I value this in terms of
this versus another black Kareem into
the future a new one
would be different so I'd apply a sort
of declining in the discount rate here
I'd keep the value of this constant this
to me in a year's time is probably worth
even more because I got even more used
to using it and I'm now today so I'm
applying a different discount function
for this one versus this one swapping
today versus the future this is what
happens when you talking about goods if
this were not a black brick for a
sandwich right what do you think the
value of this sandwich is to me tomorrow
if it's this particular sandwich is
worth nothing it'll be stale right but
if it's a sandwich swapped tomorrow for
today well I'm hungry right now I'm not
going to be that hungry this time
tomorrow right I'm not lecturing
tomorrow so its value is less so
therefore I apply a discount factor to
the distinguish which is quite steep if
you work it out I mean it's probably
I'll say well sandwich to me is worth
five dollars today tomorrow is worth a
lot less the same sandwich it delivered
tomorrow so and when we talk about
social discount rates then we have to
look at factors the time value if you
like what's the value of some service to
society today versus the same service to
society a year or ten years or 50 years
down the line and you also got to look
at how production is changing in other
words what's the increase in per capita
production now versus the future versus
the future and these are the things that
go into something which you learn about
called the Ramseys equation the value of
something in time as in preference
future versus now and the actual
quantities that are being produced and
you know the choice of society of
getting more later versus automatically
because of GDP growing per capita GDP is
one of the elements which fit which
figures as part of the discount rate
those
would have been familiar with the stern
review would have remembered numbers
like point one percent as the the time
factor and one point three percent as
the GDP growth per capita factor had
leading to his conclusion of the use of
a one point four percent discount rate
but these are discount rates so the
question also should I should come to
you this is a social discovery this is
society's thinking you should also has a
question does this always have to be
positive and can there be a minus one
point four well it depends what you as a
community are consuming if you had no
availability of produced goods and the
only things that you were consuming were
ecosystem services food and water
basically and clothes perhaps and if you
knew for sure that your population in
the community was going up and that the
the quantity of ecosystem services
produced was going down and guess what
that's not a surprising conclusion that
tends to happen then you might provide
then you might apply a negative discount
rate so it is possible to have
communities and context in which
discount rates are negative as in things
a year down the line are worth more to
you as a society compared to what they
are today that is perfectly possible so
even these are possible and please do
ask rich and see as different answers to
these questions and the final question
should be is there an ethical choice
involved out here since we are deciding
these numbers are these just normative
numbers are they just numbers that can
simply be plucked from some spreadsheet
and applied or are we making an ethical
choice and here's how I would think
about it we had way back in 2008 we had
done something like a kind of literature
survey of forest valuations and we
checked the discount rates that were
used by this the scientists and
economists who written them and most of
them they were about thirty of these
most of them had discount rates between
three and five percent and on average it
was around four percent so here's what
four percent means and it's basically a
simple arithmetic calculation to see
what four percent discounting means so
if you apply a four percent discount
rate what you're actually saying is that
something that's worth today a million
dollars to us as a community or a
society
if you apply a discount rate of 4%
across two generations that's 50 years
then the value of that comes out to
140,000 so if you are trading off
something today you're valuing something
that's received by a grandchild in 50
years time at $140,000 and you're saying
the same thing the same service to me is
today worth to me and my community today
is worth 1 million dollars of services
then you are making an ethical decision
which is that stuff to my grandchildren
and to this society's grandchildren is
worth approximately 1/7 compared to what
they're worth to us today now is that a
ethical choice or an unethical choice
and here's two alternative ways of
looking at that so if the society that
is making this decision is you and me
like we are fairly well-to-do people we
can afford to look after our children I
find it very difficult to justify this
as an ethical choice to my two daughters
as in their way you know I'm just
changing off your children's future at
1/7 of what it is today but if our
society were a poor community we and we
don't know where our next meal comes
from then it is important for us to be
fed in order to maintain our children
never mind that children so then we
might apply the opposite logic as in a
high discount rate to the future because
what's coming to us today from nature is
worth a lot more to our society compared
to what may come to us the same thing in
50 years time so we would have a
different ethical perspective on that
more important to feed me and my babies
now as against worry about their
children in 50 years time these are
ethical choices they're complex societal
ethical choices and we have to recognize
these when we undertake valuation and
make use of discount rates I want to
leave you with a question which
something to mull over which is some is
an issue which does come up because very
often we find that those who are
applying discount rates as part of their
their government calculations tend to
use the same discount rate irrespective
of the asset that is being compared so
an example that I use here is basically
a dam a hydroelectricity dam that is
being built and a discount rate is being
applied based on governments
statistics and and and assumptions on
the way the economy's being managed and
on the other side there is a forest
which is being submerged which will of
course lose ecosystem service values to
society and to local communities now the
question is is it correct to use the
same discount rate and go back to this
idea that there is a theory which
suggests that you should look at not
only your time preference for those
services not only whether those services
are good to you today versus later but
how are they changing with time are
those services increasing with time or
decreasing are those services being
consumed by more people in future or
less people in future and if the answer
is that those services compared to
electricity which is being produced not
just by my hydroelectric dam today but
also by ten other forms of renewable
energy which I am planning for and are
going to be produced in in 20 40 years
time of 10 years time if the increase in
energy use per capita is a given and if
the amount of energy that has been
produced to meet those consumption needs
of energy is a given then why should I
not be applying a higher interest rate
on the energy side of this trade-off
choice versus a lower or a potentially
negative interest rate god forbid to the
natural flow side of this it's not
trivial point it's not a straightforward
point to think that these two non
comparable assets should of course be
treated with the same discount rate and
finally some of this act this thinking
that I'm describing to you today is
actually not new and I discovered it
quite by chance in reading crow Tila
which is an old Journal article way back
from 1967 and these are his actual
quotations from that article so I just
point these out to you that some of this
potentially controversial thought is
actually there in Tortola 1967 he's in
the first paragraph what he's saying is
that consumption saving behavior is
motivated by a desire to leave your
heirs in his state as well as by the
utility to be obtained by consumption so
he's talking about withheld consumption
and the utility that provides pointing
the finger to the next point which is
the asset the fact that utility doesn't
only come about through consumption but
about having assets and decreasing them
leaving
to the next generation that also has
utility that's value that you derive
from non use and non news values do
exist and then the final point is about
the point that my last example was which
is a symmetry that the quantitative
significance of the asymmetry and the
implications of technological advances
for producing industrial goods on the
one hand and natural environments on the
other has got to be recognized and he
sees these as different asset classes so
some of this is actually there in
literature which is quite some time ago
and finally these are the the key
messages that I think as you discuss
with with rich I leave it for him to to
go through but I'll go on to the next
topic which is from the the chapter at
the set as reading for you today which
is about the ethics the value
articulating institutions and the
context of valuation valuation as a
human institutions well firstly value
articulating institutions what is meant
by institution as this itself is a
question and thankfully both Douglas
north as well as button who's the
scholar who's been quoted NT have
comparable definitions here because
Douglas talks about basically rules of
the road as institutions and within that
group he includes constitutions laws
taxation insurance market regulation and
other forms of informal societal
behavior customs habits and ideologies
so he sees those as human institutions
and likewise des veteran who's the one
that the teeb group has followed and
Retin calls this constructed set of
rules or typification 's and he goes on
to talk about the basis for the kind of
society you are and what that means in
terms of the kind of valuation you will
exercise so if you are a society which
is largely cartesian as in
judeo-christian context and developed
like we are here you might argue and you
might use the typical valuation
techniques that we all familiar with in
which you will talk about CVM revealed
preference stated preference etc if you
are more a community which is a
democratic community which works with
consultation and deliberation and
sitting together in rooms and so on well
you might follow that approach to
you might follow a social process method
as gone
and finally if it's any kind of society
but hugely complex complex and I will
come to what kinds of complexities that
are then you might just have to follow
multi-criteria methods which is very
often what tends to become the norm
because as I mentioned the pure
valuation exercise actually loses
significance when it gets into policy
space it just becomes one of the inputs
towards the policy decision I think
fundamentally what we have to recognize
institutions matter that the context of
the institution matters and the
ecosystem service will vary depending on
what kind of institution is doing the
valuation it's often been said and I'll
I'll try and question this this
assumption later but it's often been
said that your background as a society
where there's a judeo-christian
developed society or whether it's a more
community minded tribal type of society
makes a difference as to how you value
and there's an element of truth there so
what is being said is that seeing men as
inheritors of Earth seeing men as as if
you like owners of and custodians of
ecosystems and custodians of the planet
is an attitude is a social attitude is a
cultural attitude that is imbibed within
the judeo-christian tradition and that
leads to its own kinds of valuation and
some of the stuff that we are working on
in the tea group and elsewhere tends to
reflect that kind of society whereas
there are the kinds of societies there's
world views which would suggest that man
is not just Homo economicus the man
could well be homo recipients in some
says in some situations and that sort of
view is also supported by thinking
within within the space of behavioral
science and behavioral economics that is
not only about taking a Cartesian
approach it's not only about taking very
much a judeo-christian culture a
backdrop to your thinking
fundamentally what is said is that
approaches such as willingness to pay
approaches such as stated preference and
revealed preference methods tend to work
within the former context whereas
approaches such as deliberative methods
and discussion methods and process
methods tend to work more in the second
kind of the more community-based
societies and this is the one thing
which is there in the tea which I am
most upset with because they keep
comparing or they have compared amongst
other people quantum mechanics with
evaluation and let me tell you as an
exposition says nothing in comparison
but all that they are saying is actually
the whole idea that in quantum mechanics
you can't determine something to a point
where you know it's energy and you know
its location and know both of them
exactly the same time because the
measurement of physical quantities makes
a difference to your knowledge of the
physical quantities and it to some
extent what the comparison being drawn
here is a little bit stretched is that
well in the same way who you are what
institution you are which people you are
which culture you're from makes a
difference as to what the value is
but anyway it's it's a bit of a stretch
point in my opinion now I come on to the
challenges so use as if those were not
challenges enough I've described to you
the ethical challenges in discounting
and some of the conceptual challenges
there I've described to you some of the
context issues that are there are a
problem but there are more to come
because the complexity of economic
valuation takes on different layers
different dimensions so there's an issue
in terms of just the pure biophysical
complexity every location is different
you can't compare one with the other one
mangrove versus another mangrove versus
a third will behave differently
depending on where they are what kind of
ecosystem background you're looking at
location wind direction etc etc what
value communities derive in one place or
the other will depend on what kind of
fish species what kind of impacts on
climate and their willingness to pay for
whatever they get from a mangrove so
these things matter but dynamics are not
well understood we still don't
understand sufficiently the processes
and the functions of ecosystems to be
able to be totally confident when we are
using valuations
but we do nevertheless and that is
something that we have to recognize many
systems reach thresholds and this sees
to deliver the functions in a linear
kind of way even otherwise that don't
deliver linearly but certainly close to
thresholds you test the resilience of a
system and you certainly don't have
anything close to a linear approximation
being valid and finally priorities
evaluation depend for the same ecosystem
in the same place and the same services
depending on who's asking and who's me
asked so you could end up with local
communities feeling that the value of
the mangroves for fisheries is the
highest or you could end up with
visitors feeling of the value of the
mangroves for siting pink flamingos is
highest and the answers are different
because the locals don't care I think
for sighting birds that they are totally
familiar and bored with but they do care
for the fish that they eat and so on and
finally property rights sometimes the
issues of how you value is enshrined in
property rights and sometimes these are
recognized and at other times they're
not recognized and if decisions are made
at a policy level and at a legislative
level which displace property rights
then that creates its own level of
problems and and it is a risk on
valuation to not recognize that in
addition to the the complexity there's
also the context because the context
could be a landscape context where it
matters whether it's mixed-use or not
whether it's approximate areas which are
agricultural or not geological context
as well as political context because
even politically if you're two states
adjacent to each other where forests in
one clearly providing resilience as well
as freshwater regulating regulation for
the other then it's the question as to
who's valuing it if you're valuing it
you might apply one logic if there's
receiving States valuing it then it
might apply them another logic and water
gets involved because even if there
aren't two states within the same
country and we've have examples of where
valuations are implicitly being done
because people recognize smart countries
will recognize that exported food grains
are basically imported water shortage
and nobody really wants long-term what
water shortage that's a landscape
context then there's a policy context as
in what are you trying to solve when you
put this valuation together and the
purpose what we trying to address
poverty fresh water soil fertility
combination of all of these
institutional contexts we've talked
about that scale this is something we've
not discussed but something like a a
coral reef has got local values in terms
of fish nurseries it has got regional
and country values in terms of
ecotourism and employment values
it's got global values in terms of
carbon storage and of course global
values of of ecotourism so there are
different scales and depending on at
what scale you value you may or may not
end up with the same answers and here's
a little example which I'll give you
from my own experience earlier which
will illustrates two of these purposes
in other words how do you choose how to
value so firstly you need to state the
purpose as I've said you need to sort of
recognize the whose valuation it is
which segments of society local visitor
etc you need to recognize that too much
simplicity is wrong because there is
good literature which suggests that
solutions should be about as complex as
the problem that is being addressed and
then finally you do not want to make it
too complex because otherwise it will
just be difficult to implement so it
will not be effective so these are
aspects of valuation as well and I'll
illustrate from a personal example from
India which is with the Indian Supreme
Court's response to our work on the
green accounting project for Indian
states what actually happened there they
were looking to justify a compensate
tree award a set of compensatory
payments for deforestation by official
powers so this is not private
deforestation this is deforestation by
the likes of a coal mining company or by
the likes of some official land
acquisition for the purpose of
infrastructure or habitation and so on
so even for that there are internal
transfers done and it was being
questioned because some private
interests wanted that to be dropped in
order that they could make a private
acquisition case more it cost effective
I've got a call from the centrally
empowered Committee of the Supreme Court
if you're an Indian in India you don't
want to be called by the court and by
the police that's bad news generally
so thankfully the person calling turned
out to be a gentleman who was only
trying to do the right thing for his
country and all he wanted was numbers
which were good enough to justify what
he was trying to say so the purpose in
that this particular policymakers mind
was absolutely crystal clear he wanted
numbers which were defensible and good
and conservative and still made the
point that compensate repayments were
not hot air and that they should be
applied and then there was a logic
behind the so-called ecosystem services
which were on the back of which were
behind these compensate repayment
numbers and what actually happened is
that he took our numbers from the green
accounting project but he had to apply
it within his context so there was an
institutional context which was in the
Ministry of Environment and Forests
which was based on a a classification of
forests which had 16 ecotypes
this is based on the champion and state
those of your ecologists would be
familiar with this champion and say it
had 16 ecotypes and that classification
in the mind of this policymaker was too
complicated so he was trying to reduce
complexity by doing so he was addressing
and reducing complexity so he invented
with the help of his colleagues a subset
of six classes of biomes and those six
classes correspond it also roughly with
the classes that we had we in the green
accounting project in India had had
explored valuations of ecosystem
services and he then decided that he
needed to reflect further policy context
because his policy objective was
basically avoid deforestation that you
have to prevent dense forests from being
deforested and he wanted some degree of
recognition of the higher value of
ecosystem service from dense forests
versus degraded and open forests so he
broke that further into three categories
with the same average level so this was
being done by the policy makers you can
imagine the institution matters this the
institution is basically something which
is valuation enshrined in something
known as the centrally impart Committee
of the Supreme Court and rules and
regulations which are being reframed by
by this official in the government now I
pointed out a problem with that I said
look we've done the green accounting
project as a green accounting project
its purpose of valuation is not setting
compensator e-payments please sir please
don't do this because you will use
the most conservative estimates that you
possibly have and he heard us out and he
even asked me to write a short note on
why are valuations are conservative
which I did only to find about seven
months later that they had been attached
at the back of a Supreme Court judgment
and that's carried me but that's the
fact but basically he was aware of the
fact that these were conservative and he
made the choice to impute a certain
higher value on this logic and agreeing
with us that his that our valuations
were conservative because they were made
on the basis that whatever the
assumption range for ecosystem services
we are doing this to adjust national
accounts we don't want to create a
flutter we want to point out that
national accounting adjustments are
possible and that this is a conservative
first offering to the government of
India
so we knew that our range of assumption
choices were conservative to a point
that even by a factor of ten by one
entire order of magnitude of
conservatism was being applied so what
he did was literally multiplied our
numbers by 10 for so-called protected
areas once again reflecting a policy
priority which is that protected areas
must be conserved more and non forest
non protected areas are less so there's
a factor of 10 multiplying our numbers
for protected areas a factor of 5
multiplying our numbers for so called
sanctuaries and that was this particular
policymakers response to compare firstly
complexity and how do you respond to
that secondly purpose of valuation and
how do you recognize that you want
evaluation but it's seems to have been
produced for the wrong purpose or
different purpose and thirdly looking at
some form of benefits transfer because
he was using if you like a different set
of classification and he was trying to
address those specifications at the same
time as address complexity so this is
how the institution evaluation actually
works in places where it is applied and
yet it's not without its risks because
let me can someone point out the risk
this happened by the way you should have
the clue 2006 do you think this has been
updated since then no this is exactly
the point those formations were based on
numbers which were valid then scarcities
have increased inflation has increased
surely then there is an update required
and these are some of the lists that you
have to think about in riyadh
so we probably have to write back to him
reminding him that it's overdue for an
update so he has a visual way of
illustrating the general point about
complexity that you have complexity in
terms of systems simple and complex you
have complexity in terms of what's the
the decision-making point is it for the
individual optimization or is it
society's optimization and you have
complexity in terms of what kind of
interaction is it the sort of more
Cartesian instrumental type or is it
much more the community-based discussion
deliberation type and these two these
are planes actually so this sort of
gives you visually and a sense of how
decisions get more complex and cover a
bigger plane as you move along these
axes but that's reality that's what we
have to do complexity does make a huge
difference in the way that valuations
can be conducted and secondly
appropriateness when is it inappropriate
to value and one of the ways of doing
that is to look at complexity on the one
hand and value priority clarity on the
other and it's easier to justify
valuations which are in this box here
where you have more or less commodities
they are values they may most likely
have some market reflection and the
simple system is operating well they're
not too many values and they're not too
many services and on the other hand
where you have deep ethical convictions
working and non use values coming into
play and on the y axis as systems get
more complex so it's really the
left-hand corner which is relatively
easy to justify using valuation
techniques and as you get away from
there and into that sort of visual space
above above the curve so to speak that's
when things get more difficult on the
other hand if you have the tails sure
you have value polarity but if the
system is simple you can probably still
justify and if it is a commodity but
there are you know different levels of
complexity to that commodity you can
probably still justify and the
appropriateness of valuation but in that
big space out there above on the
right-hand side it doesn't become a bit
of a challenge I want to quickly come on
and close with the implications of
economic valuation
it's not a cost less exercise to do
value and when I say cost less it's not
a cost less not just in terms of effort
but in terms of what you are doing to
society you are potentially changing the
way their societies behave you are
viewing nature as something that can be
brought within the economic plane that's
that's a vision that's a view that's an
assumption that's not something that
automatically it that's not like sort of
given so to speak it's got to be
discussed it's got to be in short that
it happens within the appropriate policy
institutional and human context and you
are challenging questions of ownership
because the moment you bring in
valuation means it is for someone's
purpose and that purpose has to be true
in some way or the other
preserve an asset for reward or actually
pass over an award at some point and you
can end up with going against the grain
if you're talking about communities and
finally there are long term implications
in terms of some of the underlying
assumptions of classical and
neoclassical economics and spin argued
that economics does split up emotions
underlying choices from the utility of
the in the outcomes and I think that
logic if it's followed to its conclusion
can make you feel that yeah you're not
using utility appropriately as a concept
in framing these valuations and finally
there's this whole issue of nature and
culture and very often the idea that I
mentioned earlier which is something
were thinking about that you know a
judeo-christian approach tends to lead
to a Cartesian thinking which tends to
lead to the kind of TeV approach that we
talked about is actually one way of
doing things it's not the only way